go get some experience if you have no
idea what you're doing if you are trying
something you've never done before you
have zero experience before you start
and invest a ton of money into this and
risk losing everything go get some
experience okay learn from someone who's
done it and can give you some advice on
it so that when you go do it yourself
you have a higher degree of being
successful if you think about business
and making money okay making money comes
from providing value that that's one of
the most important rules in business you
want to make a lot of money provide a
lot of value to somebody if you've never
done something before how can you
provide somebody with a lot of value
it's probably not going to happen and
you learn how to give value through
experience so if you've never done
anything before before you launch go get
some experience it's not that you can't
learn by doing and learn in your own
business from from scratch but your
chances go up dramatically when somebody
can show you what to do they can teach
you the ropes and you can learn on
somebody else's dime you get paid to
make mistakes I got a question from one
of my youtube viewers love you guys nine
name time from mispronounced that I have
a question I'm planning to have my own
fashion show but I have no idea how to
make an event plan to convince sponsors
thank you very much so first of all
congrats on being willing to reach out
and ask for help okay that that's a
great step because a lot of archers to
try to do everything themselves and end
up failing and a lot of fashion shows
fail not because you don't have great
clothing but because they don't have the
support to make this thing happen my
best advice for you okay I'm not in the
fashion show business but if I was if I
wanted to start your business here's
what I would do the first thing I would
do is start researching who's been
massively successful in this I'm a big
believer in modeling success so find out
who puts on some of the biggest fashion
shows in the world and how did they get
started okay I don't care how they
make a new fashion show now whatever the
biggest fashion show in the world is I
don't care how they do it now how did
they do their first one how did it get
there first sponsor and the bigger the
company is the easier it's going to be
the find their story this is what got me
through when i started my software
company I started researching companies
like Microsoft and McAfee into it big
software companies look at how did they
get started and I use their strategies
to help me build my business and it
worked and finally after seen just
struggle after struggle after struggle I
started seeing some results I start
seeing some success so think about how
you can model somebody step two is go
work for somebody and you might be
thinking Evan what are you crazy go go
work for somebody I'm an entrepreneur
I'm doing my own thing I want to be my
own boss why why would I you know want
to start my own business and go work for
somebody else to learn the only reason
you get a job is to learn if you go work
at company that is putting on fashion
shows and doing a great job of it they
will ramp up your your experience level
and your knowledge gaps so quickly way
faster than if you try to do everything
yourself target a company that has ten
employees or so and go work for them
maybe it's for three months maybe it's
six months maybe it's a year and you
start your things on the side but on
them in the meantime you're making money
from your job you're learning the ropes
you're building experience you're
building up contact so that when you do
your own thing it has a much greater
degree much higher percentage chance of
being successful because what I don't
want to have happen for you you don't
know how you're making money right now
but I don't want you to invest
everything into this fashion show it's a
bust because you've never done it before
I need to go back and get a job and you
give up on your dream that's what I
don't want to have happen that's what
happens that most people they start up
with without any experience and they
fail and say I can't do this and go back
and get a job better to get a job sooner
in an industry is going to teach you
something and use that experience to
launch a company
so maybe not the news that you wanted to
hear but it's the best advice I have few
and it will help you save your business
so step one model success find somebody
who's already done what you're trying to
do find the biggest players in the
industry the one to a shooter successful
right now and look at how they got
started how they found their first
sponsor how they made their first
million that's where you can learn and
to go get a job working in your industry
work for a company who you look up to
who you respect you want to be in a
couple years and learn how they got
there and get paid to make mistakes good
luck and believe for those you're
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below let me hear what you
have to think leave a comment let me
know what you think about the video you
have a question leave it below make a
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon